[Music]
tonight more signs of normalcy the first
major convention to take place since the
pandemic will begin
tomorrow world of concrete will bring in
thousands of visitors and
joe moeller spoke to area business
owners he's live tonight outside of the
las vegas convention center with what
they had to say joe
there's a lot of excitement surrounding
world of concrete for a number of
reasons not only is this the
first convention to come back here to
las vegas but it's also the
first show to happen in the new west
hall of the convention center now you
can see the setup happening
just west of this new west hall a lot of
people are excited about this especially
businesses in the area owners and
managers say
they're happy to see this once again
it's like
coming home in a way the convention
industry is making a comeback
everything's back to normal and it's
great 60 thousand people are expected to
be in las vegas this week for world of
concrete
it's right in our back parking lot
peppermill general manager peggy orth
has been waiting for the conventions to
return
that's what we do you know we have our
regulars for the last 40 years
same people coming with every single
convention millions usually flock to las
vegas for trade shows but in 2020
convention attendance was down 74
percent due to the pandemic
firefly on paradise just down the street
from the convention center recently
reopened
world of concrete's a big one owner john
simmons says businesses like his rely on
those visitors
all the people that work in all these
businesses like our restaurants and on
the strip and everything else that
depend on these tourists and these
conventions
they they get fed and then they spend
the money in the local economy and it
just helps everybody
world of concrete is the first of many
conventions planned for june and the
coming months
the conventions usually come at a time
that you need them
and we needed them more than ever last
year and
this year it's nice to see them coming
back
now back out here live you're taking
another look at the setup outside the
convention center around 1500 companies
will be on display here
starting tomorrow attendees should
expect some covert related changes this
all starts
at 9 30 in the morning and if you do
work in this area expect some convention
related traffic
reporting live here outside the
convention center joe mohler 8 news now